we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
caller who says straight up i think
we've got to be ready for a trump
reelection take a listen hey david this
is luke from connecticut I just wanted
to get your thoughts or opinions on my
current thought that we need to buckle
up because as far as I can see Trump is
going to win again I know that extremely
early to make that prediction but I I
just don't see the majority of Americans
being intelligent enough to see what's
right in front of them and unfortunately
Trump is not a master at propaganda he
just a master at basically fooling
people who are easily fooled
I mean pulling the wool over the eyes of
the blind does it make you a master
propagandist it just makes you a con man
and he seems to be very good at doing
that so I hope everything in my body
that doesn't happen but I think we did
luck a lot and I'd like to know what you
think about that oh thanks I basically
agree I mean I've said this before I
think that this is an election that will
come down to turnout this is an election
that will depend on who actually gets
out to vote it's going to be an election
that will in part depend on who is the
Democratic candidate but only partially
because there are so many other things
going on attempts to interfere with the
election voting machines voter
suppression but all of these ultimately
or mostly relate to turnout and
unfortunately we've run the numbers a
president can win reelection
with a twenty eight percent approval
rating because of the electoral college
system that we have and because anywhere
from forty to fifty percent of the
country simply does not vote so I hope
it doesn't happen I'm with you but this
is the alarm I've been sounding now for
six months or longer
and we better get our you-know-what
together on the Left if we want to
prevent it from happening we've got a
great bonus show today we will talk
about all sorts of different things that
will be of great interest to you I am
sure get instant access to the bonus
show by becoming a member or a patron
that's it for the show but much more
show coming up on the bonus show